[Music]
[Applause]
please be seated
good morning my name is Lisa Rosen mesh
and I am the proud Dean of the Columbia
School of general studies welcome to the
class day ceremony celebrating the
accomplishments of the extraordinary
General Studies class of 2018 I am
especially pleased that we have with us
today the president of Columbia
University Lee Bollinger and executive
vice president and dean of the Faculty
of the Arts and Sciences David Madigan
in addition we are honored to have with
us today Julie Schwartz Dean of graduate
and undergraduate studies at the Jewish
Theological Seminary
we are honored to welcome Vice President
David Chang from the City University of
Hong Kong
and Frederic me own president of science
Po they and their colleagues have joined
us this morning to celebrate the
graduation of students in our joint
programs with the Jewish Theological
Seminary our dual BA program of the Seon
suppo and our dual BA program with the
City University of Hong Kong all of
these students have earned two
bachelor's degrees in four years one
from jts Seon SPO or the City University
of Hong Kong and another one from
Columbia University I would like to
extend a warm welcome to our class day
speaker olympian sasha cohen GS class of
2016 i would like to welcome members of
the GS Board of Visitors members of the
Executive Board of the GS Alumni
Association and of course members of our
distinguished faculty in the arts and
sciences who have been your teachers
mentors and champions and they're all
here thank you
we have a very special guest joining us
on stage today here to see his
granddaughter
Shanna Polly graduate today this person
is Milton Mickey mushaira
this is very special and I want Mickey
if you could just there he is
Mickey started at the school of general
studies in 1949 just two years after the
creation of GS in 1947 but his studies
were soon interrupted by military
service in Korea he returns in 1952
he he returned in 1952 after service and
graduated in 1954 but today only 64
years later he joins us to celebrate his
granddaughter's accomplishments and we
get to congratulate Mickey and his
family on their Colombia legacy at the
school of general studies
finally but certainly not least I have
the honor and privilege to welcome Peter
J on my predecessor in there
and the amazing
and he is the amazing dean emeritus of
the school of general studies
I am honored to be the ninth dean of the
school of general studies and the first
alumna to be Dean of this exceptional
school as a proud alumna I know
firsthand how transformative GS is for
students who pass through our doors at
Lewis and Hall I also know how much our
students and graduates do to transform
the world around them during and after
their time at Columbia the creation of
GS 71 years ago represents a true
milestone in the evolution of
undergraduate education at Ivy League
universities there are two major factors
that make GES unique first we actively
recruit students who have taken an
untraditional path and integrate them
fully into our distinguished rigorous
undergraduate program second we are the
incubator for innovative dual and joint
degree programs which gives students a
unique opportunity to engage with
cutting-edge international education I
am a proud graduate of our flagship
joint program with Liss College at the
Jewish Theological Seminary
the joint program was established over
sixty years ago twenty-eight joint
program students will graduate this week
we are especially pleased that 55
students will be graduating from our
dual be a program with Seon suppo Seon
SPO is the leading European University
in the social sciences and we are also
super excited that ten students from our
joint BA program with the City
University of Hong Kong will also
graduate today the presence of the of GS
in the classroom bringing both
traditional and untraditional students
enhances significantly the quality of
the intellectual discourse among
students and faculty and our community
and GS makes the Columbia undergraduate
experience unlike that and any other Ivy
League university there is absolutely no
doubt that the success of GS is due to
the commitment of the Columbia faculty
to our mission and our students @ GS you
will find four hundred and sixty
veterans in of the US military a hundred
and six who will be graduating this week
this is the largest cohort of US
veterans to graduate from Colombia since
World War two and we should know that no
other Ivy League or selected private
university comes even close to that
number we are without doubt the gold
standard for undergraduate veterans
education in the u.s. whether GS
students are first-generation college
students actors dancers parents Olympic
medalists like our keynote speaker today
sasha cohen or community college
graduates musicians entrepreneurs
international students or students who
have simply overcome challenging life
circumstances they all receive the same
superb education as all other columbia
undergraduates and they excel members of
the class of 2018 I hope you appreciate
how valuable you and your fellow geezers
have been to the intellectual life of
Columbia you represent the cutting edge
of American and international
undergraduate education and you have
proven yourselves through your academic
accomplishments and your dedication to
one another and Columbia we are
privileged to count you as lifelong
members of Columbia intellectual and
alumni communities now I will get to
introduce our president under president
Bollinger's leadership Columbia stands
again at the very top rank of great
research universities distinguished by
academic excellence historic
institutional developments and
innovative and sustainable approach to
global engagement and unprecedented
levels of alumni involvement and
financial stability during his tenure
president Bollinger conceived
and led the university's most ambitious
expansion in over a century with the
creation of the Manhattanville campus in
West Harlem president Bollinger vision
for Columbia's engagement in the world
led to the development of a network of
eight Columbia global centers on four
continents and the creation of new
venues of the university's home campus
supporting global conversations and
scholarship including the world leaders
forum and the Committee on global
thoughts most recently president
Bollinger announced the creation of a
new institution embedded in the
university called Columbia world
projects in describing this effort
president Bollinger writes what
universities have not yet done in
creating institutions that aim across a
broad range of specific topics to
connect academic work and the broad
capacities of the academic community
with organization and parties beyond the
Academy that possessed the power and
influence to transform all of this into
concrete consequences benefiting
humanity this is the purpose of Columbia
world projects Lee Bollinger is also a
committed educator continuing to teach
an undergraduate course on the First
Amendment even while he leads this great
university you should all know that his
support for the students of the School
of General Studies has been unwavering
when he interviewed me to be the ninth
Dean of this school of general studies
president Bollinger said to me that
while he is confident in the knowledge
that I will work to bring the school of
general study to even higher levels of
distinction he also wanted to make sure
that as Dean I would love our students
and I can assure you president Bollinger
that I do it is my privilege
to introduce to you the 19th president
of Columbia University Lisi Bollinger
thank you very much Lisa that was
extremely generous and thoughtful I am
will have the opportunity to speak to
you on Wednesday so I'm going to save
everything I have to say until then I
just want to make a few very quick
comments first of all I want to
acknowledge the tremendous feeling of
satisfaction and of pleasure that the
parents and families feel in watching
you graduate this is a moment that is
seared in the memory of every family
member forever and we follow you around
we love everything you do this is this
is a time in life when it's just
unconvicted adoration and we we
understand that the second thing I want
to say is that we we really have been
blessed with truly truly great Dean's of
General Studies and of course there's
Peter and then there's Peter and that's
the end of so Peter Peter the Great is
our is our our tradition of great Dean's
in in general studies and I want to say
Lisa is just going to be a spectacular
Dean as well it's it's something where
you bring an intellectual distinction
she's really really find an accomplished
scholar but also very much involved in
the world in in ways that help people
enormous Lea but just has a love of this
institution and view that she just
exhibited and those are all the
ingredients of a worthy successor to
Peter on so thank you Lisa for doing
this is also the last graduation for
general studies of David Madigan who has
been the executive vice president for
arts and sciences and David is someone
who has really really worked with Peter
and now Lisa to help general studies in
every possible way and behind the scenes
and it's something that you don't fully
appreciate but I want to give us very
special thanks and acknowledgement to
David Madigan who's stepping down
so just two very quick comments one is
that general studies as Lisa and we say
every single year is a truly truly
unique rare institution there's nothing
else like it in the United States and
possibly the world and that's that's
something that Columbia takes enormous
pride in Columbia would not be Columbia
without general studies so it's a very
very warm thanks to you
and the last thing I'd say which I will
expand on on Wednesdays this is a very
unusual moment in the history that
you're graduating at this at this time
the very things we stand for is a
university reason civil inquiry
objectivity truth facts understanding
knowledge bringing to bear whatever
thinking we can on hard problems this is
something that is under challenged and
whatever your political views this is
not something on which one really can
have a different view and have
meaningful civilization so we as a
university feel particularly strongly
about the importance of these basic
bedrock values and we hope that you have
been steeped in them here and will carry
forth those basic norms into your lives
thank you very much congratulations
Thank You president Bollinger Frederick
Mian was appointed president of Seon SPO
in April 2013 under President my own
Seon SPO continues to be a leader in
education through its innovative
academic programs and its commitment to
remain open to the world and its
diversity president me Owens emphasis on
and dedication to internationalization
pedagogical innovation in excellence in
the Social Sciences position C on SPO
among the world's leading institutions
of higher education see on SPO is one of
the founding members of the Allianz
program a transatlantic joint venture of
excellence supported by the French
Ministry of Foreign Affairs bringing
together Columbia University and the
three major French institutions every
year hundreds of students from all over
the world are part of one of the 23
joint programs and dual degree programs
offered to undergraduate and graduate
students between the four universities
including the nearly three hundred
students in the dual ba program between
Columbia University and Seon SPO
president Mian has been a great partner
and friend to Columbia University I am
pleased that he will be our partner for
many more years in February 2018 Seon
spose governing bodies confirmed
president mio in second term as
president please join me in welcoming
president Frederick Mian
[Applause]
dear president Bollinger dear vice
president Madigan dear Dean Rosen match
dear members of the faculty and
administration dear family members and
most importantly dear graduates it is
for me a great privilege and a great
honor to be with you today as we
celebrate the GS graduates class of 2018
and I am in awe of being standing in
front of you on this podium today thank
you so much Dean Rosen much for inviting
me to be with you today
thank you for this very warm and
generous welcome and congratulations on
your appointment as the ninth Dean of
this phenomenal school of general
studies of Columbia University the
common history between seongho and GS
started 8 years ago when together with
your predecessor might much esteemed
friend Dean Peter on we launched our
groundbreaking duo ba we made history
then by linking for what I believe was
the very first time two global
institutions at undergraduate level in
joining forces with Columbia we knew it
sha spoke that we were providing the
very best space for our future global
actors to emerge and that we were
creating an environment a truly unique
truly international environment in which
outstanding and curious man minded young
people from across the globe the globe
could flourish eight years down the road
we've certainly come a long way and
we're extremely proud of what has proven
to be an incredibly successful
collaboration at the global level DRGs
graduates each
and every one of you has of course also
come a long way in joining GS you all
took a brave step that of choosing a
school where innovative programs are
made possible where out of the ordinary
life stories welcomed cherished and
nurtured at shows Po we are in awe of
the brilliance of the brilliance and
diversity of the GS community a number
of you here today are of course I
confess particularly close to my heart
they chose to have not just one but two
on the mattress and to start with they
chose to leave their native Singapore
Turkey or Canada among so many others in
order to spend two years in the French
provinces although some of them at the
time didn't even speak a word of French
I remember meeting you all
on your various campuses for the very
first time four years ago you were young
you still are young fresh you're still
somewhat fresh excited and nervous but
before our eyes you grew into mature
young adults capable of achieving
academic success whilst also discovering
who you were that is to say whilst truly
becoming yourselves your second leap
into the unknown was Columbia at
Columbia you had to step away from your
beloved do party dersu party you had to
discover the endless joys of problem
sets and research papers you swept the
notoriously delicious whose sandwiches
for the more aesthetic salads at sweet
green
and of course those of you who spend
their first two lives at Xian PO on our
campus in the city of us had to jump
from one type of Bollinger to another
but they lost none of the sparkle in the
process today CEO SPO and Columbia are a
fundamental part of your identities and
the skills you've developed over the
past four years have developed in each
of you a keen sense of critical
observation with regards to a
multicultural context and prepared you
for what I hope will be a life of
service in a truly global world
incidentally I realized as I flew over
from Paris the calculator go that out of
the four US and French presidents that
you've known during your time at Xian PO
in Colombia three were graduates of
either Champoux or Columbia I shall not
name names but please think of expanding
the list because graduates the future is
yours the time has come for you to get
out into the world and as you go forth I
beseech you to be ambitious in
proportion to the dreams that we Harbor
for you I beseech you to be generous in
proportion to the gifts that have been
so lavishly bestowed upon you I beseech
you to be humble in proportion to the
number and magnitude of the challenges
with which our planet is faced I beseech
you to be joyful in proportion to the
gloom that so many feel it is their duty
to spread and I beseech you to give as
much love as you possibly can because to
quote the words a French writer
bonanno's every life is lived under the
sign of desire and fear unless it be
lived under the sign
of love congratulations to each and
every one of you happy graduation
make us proud thank you
Thank You president Lyon I am now
thrilled to introduce to you our next
speaker who will have the honor to
introduce the 2018 class day speaker in
addition to his full time career in
academia economics as senior lecturer in
Columbia University's department of
economics professor Sunil Gulati was
until just recently the President of the
United States Soccer Federation where he
served four consecutive terms
professor colotti is a widely popular
teacher and a member of our faculty and
community
professor Sunil Gulati
some seven years ago after the first
session of principles of economics
having reviewed the syllabus a student
approached me in the patio outside of
squirming ORN with a midterm date
conflict not the first time I've heard
such nonsense her precise words I have
this skating thing my somewhat sarcastic
response was sorry but if it was the
Olympic Trials or something to which she
responded well I've done the Olympic
Trials and the Olympics at which point
the students standing next to her
screamed oh my god are you sasha Cohen
embarrassed I looked up and indeed it
was sasha Cohen our class day speaker
this morning is a distinguished Olympic
athlete and medalist G s class of 2016
like many of you extraordinary
accomplishments before during and for
many of you soon-to-be after you're here
starting as a gymnast sasha made the
switch to skating at age 7 and began
training seriously at age 11 in 2001 she
suffered a broken back but against all
odds recovered quickly and qualified for
the 2002 Olympics where she finished
fourth in the 2006 US Figure Skating
Championships she took home the silver
medal and the Olympic at the Olympic
Games that year the same she's a
three-time World Championship medalist
and placed among the top 20 in three top
three in 20 consecutive competitions
since 2003 Sasha
enrolled at GS in 2011 steps of scorn
notwithstanding she did quite well here
during her time as a student she
continued to tour and perform with stars
on ice she supported figure skating in
Harlem a nonprofit organization that
aims to empower girls of color through
education and access to the artistic
discipline of figure skating as well as
the Robin Hood Foundation an
organization dedicated to fighting
poverty in New York City she graduated
magna laude in 2016
with a degree in political science Sasha
continued to pursue her interest in
media after graduation as a news
associate at 60 minutes and a set of
content at Zig currently she works as a
disruptive change analyst from Morgan
Stanley speaks for the Olympic Committee
and volunteers with several charitable
organizations she also continues to
write with pieces published in The New
York Times and Sports Illustrated
including a recent op-ed about adjusting
to life after being an Olympian in 2016
Sasha was inducted into the US Figure
Skating Hall of Fame Olympic medalist
Hall of Fame a skating thing indeed
please welcome please join me in
welcoming sasha cohen as our class day
speaker sasha cohen
Wow you've you've done your research I
don't think I have much left to say well
let me start with good morning it's
early I can't believe that it was
literally just two years ago that I was
sitting where you are now I want to
thank you for the tremendous honor of
allowing me to speak to you on this
momentous occasion I want to thank
president Bollinger executive vice
president and dean of faculty Madigan
Dean Rosen mensch
members of faculty and administration
family members and most importantly the
graduates first of all take a second and
just look around look at what you're
wearing
you made it take this moment to really
reflect on your time here maybe like me
you will always remember the Sun on your
face as you sat on the steps of low
library in the first warm days of spring
the happy chatter the longer days that
anticipation of summer take a minute to
really appreciate what being a student
here meant to you the privilege of
joining a class of individuals who came
to Columbia School of general studies
with a multitude of experiences before
even stepping foot here
veterans dancers artists musicians and
those who took a slightly different path
you're here because you wanted to be
here not because College was the next
logical step and today you're graduating
I have to tell you I was genuinely taken
by surprise when I got an email from
Dean Rosen Mitch asking me to be your
speaker she had read my authored in the
New York Times about what it was like to
retire at 25 this past year has brought
multiple opportunities for me to write
speak and find what feels like truth for
me
every four years the Winter Olympics
stirs up a flurry of memories and
emotions reminding me of my competitive
days and just how short an athlete's
career is I spoke to the 2018 Winter
Olympic team just last month on what to
expect after a lifetime dedicated to
their sport the disorientation at having
a lifelong goal dissolve their
ready-made sense of purpose vanish and
the absolute futility of thinking that
something else could fully replace an
athlete's way of life I'm still
adjusting but I feel like I'm finally
finding a post-olympic
rhythm today I'm speaking to you as a
peer and hope the lessons that I've
learned and I'm still learning will be
useful to you the world knows me as a
figure skater two-time olympian and
olympic silver medalist some people
however think my best work was my cameo
in blades of glory
Catching Will Ferrell's jockstrap
which might very well be true more often
than you might expect
people are rather disappointed when they
don't get Borat but if you were paying
attention he always goes by his full
name Sacha Baron Cohen
anyways I spent my childhood and teenage
years training with a singular
motivation becoming an Olympian it was
lonely and pressure-packed
I lived in a world of my own thoughts
intensified by my expectations at the
age of 12 I chose to be homeschooled to
increase my training time and at 17 when
most of my friends made a move to attend
University I moved across the country
and back again to follow coaches I
believe and make me a better half late I
could say that I missed out on a normal
childhood but to be honest I never
wanted one for better or worse
dedicating two decades of my life to a
sport shaped me I know the power of an
irrational level of commitment what it
feels like to have the weight of the
world on your shoulders and how
satisfying it can be to make personal
sacrifices for your dreams in 2010 at
the age of 25 I decided to give
competitive skating one last chance and
try to make my third Olympic team I did
not make the team that night but I did
make a decision to leave my competitive
skating career behind although I had no
idea what would be next at that point I
was spending half of my free time at the
public library and I was hungry for a
structured education I decided to apply
to Columbia school of general studies
and as you know I needed to write a
personal essay as part of the
application well I hadn't written an
essay in eight years and I hated writing
I couldn't do justice to my thoughts and
feelings I'd never develop patience or
the practice of writing in fact when I
was supposed to be writing essays during
my senior year of high school my teacher
told me it'd be okay if I just kept a
journal during the Olympics so too no
great surprise my writing wasn't I
needham work my sister kindly read it
over took a deep breath before giving me
a long look you know one of those looks
that really looks and wonders what's
going on up here my little sister who
graduated from Barnard in 2010 Phi Beta
Kappa magna laude double majored in
econ in Psych total slacker you know the
time she said you can't just write your
thoughts in any random order what's your
thesis what's the point did you even
make an outline by the way she said the
same thing when she read through the
rough draft of this speech some things
never change and that was the beginning
of my journey here at Columbia I was
finally a student first I learned to
write properly think critically and
understand the immense value of a
liberal arts education I learned what a
thesis was and why every professor was
so adamant that I include one in my
paper this seems like the proper moment
to thank the admissions board for
admitting me giving me the chance to
fall in love with education with
Columbia and with writing I feel like
that build-up should culminate with me
telling you that I'm now in New York
Times bestselling author no not yet at
least maybe in 20 years when I come back
but I have started to write about my
experiences and transitions from an
athlete to civilian after graduating my
first job was at a small media startup I
left that startup when funding ran out
as often happens and I went to work at
60 minutes I then applied to Columbia
School of Journalism and got in but
decided not to go well I love telling
stories that mattered I was drawn to
many other things as well I now work in
investment management identifying new
technologies that significantly changed
the investing landscape if it's a
buzzword I'm probably looking into it
outside my career search in my personal
life it's been a time of exploration and
recognition I took a trip across
the country traveled to Africa South
America Southeast Asia and Europe
I was inaugurated into the US Figure
Skating Hall of Fame it was also a time
of great sadness I lost my grandmother
to cancer and a year later found myself
facing the end of my marriage I had
moments of incredible joy and freedom
later replaced by heartache doubt and
groundlessness but that's life with its
ups its downs each experience personally
and professionally has taught me
something about myself and the way I
want to be in this world and after
watching over 30 commencement speeches
which I think could be an incredible
course offering by the way I found a
common thread the speaker's role is to
cut through the noise that has taken
over our daily consciousness of what we
think is important versus what actually
matters with that in mind I have seven
pieces of advice my first piece of
advice fitting in is overrated I was an
overactive overwhelming child I never
fit in anywhere not with my teachers not
with my classmates I bounced through
several elementary schools always
sticking out and not in a good way one
teacher thought I was deaf because I
never listened to instructions
another concerned teacher gave my mother
a book on how to deal with juvenile
delinquents I was often sent to the
principal's office usually for doing
cartwheels instead of lining up during
assembly talking while the teacher was
talking or not putting my art project
down to move on when it was time for
math I like to see my projects to
completion what can I say my
pediatrician determined I had ADHD and
recommended medication my parents
however opted for gymnastics three hours
a day
my life would have been very different
if my parents had chosen a path to help
me fit in by putting me on Ritalin but
thankfully my parents who also can never
be accused of trying to fit in put me
into gymnastics which led to ice skating
which in turn led to an Olympic and
professional career as a figure skater
there's always another way than the
normal path and it usually leads to the
better more authentic you honor your
differences and channel them lesson to
just show up every day even when you
think you cannot because when you show
up you are defeating the voice inside
that wants to give up as a competitive
athlete nine days out of ten were rough
my body ached and injuries were always
present each day of practice leading up
to a big competition brought with it a
heavy feeling in my chest and
butterflies in my stomach
my inner voice asked would I be prepared
and would I live up to my potential
this mental and physical pressure filled
me with doubt but I showed up every day
at the rink at the gym a physical
therapy by showing up no matter how I
felt by putting in the work I built
something and after years and years of
showing up standing my ground and
fighting against the pain and fear I
found myself at my second Olympic Games
during my long program at the Olympics
my nightmare came to life as I fell on
my first jump then badly botched the
second those moments were probably the
most difficult of my life with the
entire world watching as my dreams
shattered in a few seconds I made a
choice to keep fighting to show up for
the girl who had spent a lifetime
preparing preparing for this moment you
can't control how things turn out but
you can show up I ended up skating the
rest of my program perfectly and winning
the silver medal now I want to segue to
a few lessons I learned since graduation
unlike the committe the usual
commencement speaker who graduated
decades ago has built an epic career and
has it all figured out I'm still
navigating the world but I do have two
whole years post graduation on you and
I've been busy lesson three give
yourself permission to wander and even
to get lost
in the words of someone much wiser not
til we are lost do we begin to find
ourselves Henry David Thoreau not until
recently did I learn the necessity of
giving myself permission not to know
permission to let life unfold if you're
a type-a personality like I am this
sounds incredibly irresponsible I used
to have every minute of my life planned
out in four year Olympic cycles failing
to plan was quite literally planning to
fail maybe that's true in sports and in
war but it's certainly not true in life
I began the process of letting life
unfold when I moved to New York City I
didn't know where I would live what what
my major would be or what life would be
like outside of an ice rink but I did
know that forcing and planning were no
longer serving me deciding to stop
skating and starting over it was
terrifying but one of the best decisions
that I've ever made lesson number four
be vulnerable the willingness to share
your vulnerabilities will add incredible
depth to your life you will find that
you're not the only one who struggles I
spent a whole life putting up walls
keeping people out and trying to be
perfect not saying anything that might
result in criticism or make me appear
weak in the last year however I Bank
began to publicly write about it for
Sports Illustrated BuzzFeed and the New
York Times it was terrifying to openly
admit my fears feelings of inadequacy
and how hard my post
big transition has been in print on the
internet for the whole world to read I
fully expected awkward responses and
people wondering if I have lost my mind
in sharing these deep-seated
insecurities but to my surprise it was
quite the opposite I got letters and
emails and tweets not just from skaters
athletes and Olympians from people who
had lost a loved one who felt unhinged
by a career transition who had given up
an identity in some capacity I felt an
incredible connection with these people
who in turn shared their own
insecurities with me lesson five I am an
avid quote collector and one of my
favorites is about a little bird by the
poet Aaron Hanson there is freedom
waiting for you on the breezes of the
sky and you ask what if I fall oh but my
darling what if you fly that quote
captures the fear and the doubt that so
often hold me back I have worked to
reframe fear as a welcome sign I know
that if something scares me it's
probably something I need to do from my
experience the little voice inside that
aspires but is held back by fear is spot
on I've learned to listen more often and
to listen sooner refuse to live a life
defined by what you're afraid to fail at
lesson six destinations are overrated
it's about the journey most of us don't
live this way we focus on the outcome
why is the destination the end goal so
appealing to us I think because on the
deepest level what we all want so
fundamentally is to arrive to make it to
feel validated yet I don't think we will
ever feel like we are done or have
arrived because when you do arrive it
only means you must
/ and find a new destination that's what
I learned on the Olympic podium and
again when I graduated from Columbia
lesson number seven define what success
means for you
I found that success cannot be found in
a gold medal in an A or a prestigious
job for me success is making life a
daily process that I love I want to
remind you what a big statement that is
coming from me someone who lived and
breathed the words pain is temporary
victory is forever and ambitious to a
fault and have spent a lifetime training
to compete with tangential outcomes but
in the eight years since I last competed
and in the two years since I graduated
I've realized that success takes many
forms not just the covers of magazines
and big paychecks but in the time I
spend with family and friends in the
books I get lost in the travel to remote
parts of the earth in the human
experience as you enter the real world I
encourage you to take some time and find
out what success means for you learn who
you are what you stand for and what you
value if you're ever in doubt ask your
80 year old self what you would do I
find that's where all my wisdom and
common sense comes from 80 year old
Sasha I bring her in for a conversation
now and again and she sets my priorities
straight because at the end of our lives
I believe that we will regret more what
we didn't do than what we did we will
regret that we played it safe that we
didn't take the wild adventure and that
we didn't spend more time with the
people who made us smile laugh and feel
loved thank you so much and
congratulations
Thank You sasha cohen that was wonderful
our salutatorian this year is Marisol
you after graduating from high school in
New Jersey
Marisol moved to Texas to attend the
University of Texas at Austin due to a
combination of financial issues and
personal challenges she dropped out in
the spring semester of her first year
and began working in construction and
landscaping full-time while taking night
courses part time at Austin Community
College in 2016 Marisol moved to New
York City and enrolled a GS where she
found purpose for her studies and life
with deeper insight into psychology and
the importance of seeking knowledge on
human behavior gained while working with
professor NIM Tottenham in her
developmental affective neuroscience lab
and a background as a fitness enthusiast
she went on to establish my one body one
life a nonprofit whose mission is to
emphasize the interconnectedness and
importance of mental and physical health
while making holistic health accessible
to all Marisol was named to the dean's
list in each of her semesters at GS and
was inducted into the GS Honor Society
the Columbia University saikai Honor
Society and Phi Beta Kappa she is the
recipient of the Clayton a Blaylock
scholarship and was chosen as a Gilman
scholar
looking to the future Marisol chief aim
before eventually attending business
school is to empower people by providing
them with resources and inspiration to
take control of their own health and
lifestyle through her nonprofit
please join me in welcoming the
salutatorian of the class of 2018
Marisol you
[Applause]
thank you dean rosen match esteemed
administrators honored faculty alumni
class of 2018 family and friends welcome
it is beyond an honor and pleasure to be
here with you all today Columbia is hard
it's supposed to be hard if it were easy
everyone would do it the hard it's what
makes it great this quote was put on a
screen in front of me and likely several
of you as well during jump start a
program provided by our wonderful Dean's
at GES who helped us anxious returning
students adjust not just into student
life but Columbia life now standing here
in front of you I can certainly attest
the truth behind these words Columbia is
hard but we did it I'll admit I've
always been a nerd even when I was a
college dropout I wasn't the type that
was cool by some non-traditional means I
was just a nerd dropout so what did that
make me a failure I thought so I wonder
if many of you have read on Carol
Dweck's truly enlightening research on
mindset with regards to achievement
which informs on productivity and
success it's quite relevant to why we're
all here today so I'll try to sprinkle
in how this incredibly empowering
research has been a huge influence in my
life growing up I was troubled
I had several traumatic experiences that
led me into life of depression and
anxiety from a very young age so after
graduating high school in New Jersey I
decided to move far to live a new life
and attend the University of Texas at
Austin but it was soon that I would drop
out and that day it was a low point for
me
to say the least I had panic attacks at
any given moment and often had suicidal
thoughts but why I had left that life
behind but now I've learned it is not
change in any physical state in that
case literally or your situation that
can change you change yourself from
seeing yourself as a failure no it's a
change of mindset I chose to study
psychology because I feel empowered and
believe firmly and the power of your
mind
after decades of research professor
Dweck has coined growth versus fixed
mindset with a fixed mindset one's
belief stands that you're set talents IQ
genetic endowment these are the elements
that dictates success and therefore also
failure so if you have it great but if
not you're out of luck on the contrary
with a growth mindset not only our deaf
effort and dedication required but also
capable of cultivating those very
elements of a fixed mindset intelligence
ability and so on therefore grit and
determination are the primary and
fundamental elements of success with
this perspective there is a passion and
purpose for learning as we understand
that knowledge performance an
achievement or a continuous journey
growth mindset has the power to change
your life what's your GS story I love
hearing this at events in the lounge or
just reading about all of your
incredible journeys on our website my
story well since that day I couldn't
fathom why life was not perfect after
moving to Texas my mindset has turned
from fixed to growth
my story turned from being one that was
disabled by my situations both present
and past to one that has a deep
understanding that nothing in life is a
failure rather perhaps it is not a
success yet my story is not one a chance
is a story of ruthlessly working not
just to find myself but create myself
since I was 16 I've held all kinds of
jobs not just being a waitress
babysitter salesperson of everything
from cupcakes of vitamins julienne
watches but even wearing a gorilla suit
trying to attract people into a store on
a hot Texas concrete sidewalk it was hot
I was dancing my but I'm not ashamed of
any of these jobs because they're all a
part of my story my older siblings both
finished college in three years and let
me tell you it's taking me over double
that time my father pushed us all to go
to college go to law school and then
become lawyers but I knew it was not the
path for me although I never spoke up my
incredibly intelligent siblings who are
both here today and I'm so grateful are
both lawyers at top law firms so you
could say I've been the black sheep in
my family after I dropped out of college
I entered the construction industry I
wasn't particularly interested or
knowledgeable in construction I was an
18 year old psychology major but while
working 100 plus hour weeks I learned
that you could learn anything and not
just learn but excel at it I learned
skills I never thought I would like CAD
and architectural drawings to SEO and
online marketing but most impactful to
me professional photography well
photography was originally a necessity
to invest in the landscaping business it
gave me something truly invaluable the
gift of expression may
passion for photography led to new
creative business numbers and after
moving to New York to attend Columbia
with the plan to continue in the fashion
industry I took a step back from the
camera
I felt I acknowledged that photography
was an integral part such a healing from
my lifelong depression but I felt
discouraged that I wasn't doing enough
for others now I use my photography as
one asset to work for my nonprofit as
well as in various opportunity while we
each have a unique toolbox of skills
that we have gained both on and off this
campus we can all use our unique
repertoire of ability to do the same
thing do good for yourself and for
others and this application of your
unique skill set this is the value of a
Columbia education believe it or not we
are no longer as students at Columbia we
cannot have that amazing professor who
taught you X Y or Z right by your side
or Glenn at the University Writing
Center helped bring you to revelation on
your writing but what Columbia has
provided us is with something even more
valuable it has given us the ability to
utilize those hard-earned skills on a
daily basis as they are now a part of
your intrinsic thought processes
everyone here has a different story
just look around we don't only vary an
age but past careers personal histories
we're not your conventional group of
undergraduates but you know what there
is one thing that we all have in common
that make us people who succeed none of
us are a story of chance we didn't all
let circumstances even uncontrollable
ones dictate how we will live our lives
how do I know this because we're here
because wherever you were in
your life you chose to continue
education and took initiative and that
does not just happen by chance the
people who sit to your left and your
right these are real-life heroes like my
friends Alan and sang and the 104 other
veterans who graduate with us today like
my friend Marie who put her daughter
through Colombia then came back for
herself like my friend Powell who cycled
across the country raising money for
cancer the people who sit here today
these are the people who change the
world by being who they are
I came to Colombia for a degree but I
leave beyond inspired with a family I
can be certain that the paths each and
every one of you will walk once we walk
off this campus today are not
necessarily easy ones because we are a
group of individuals that whether or not
something is easy is irrelevant we do
not fear what is hard even welcome it
and accomplish what must be done I want
to remind you all that before we had
Colombia is hard in our lives
there was something else in life that
was hard and because of how
extraordinary you all are I can be
certain it's not the last thing that
will prove difficult but more
importantly not the last thing you will
succeed at I want to add just one more
revision to that quote it's not the
great that make I mean it's not the hard
that makes it great
it's your perseverance that makes it
great congratulations to the class of
Thank You Marisol that was fantastic I
would like to invite gs vice dean Kurtis
Rogers to join me for this next
presentation this past March after five
very successful years as executive vice
president and dean of the faculty David
Madigan announced that he will step down
in August of 2018 to return to the
faculty over these past five years David
has expertly managed a portfolio of five
schools 27 departments and more than 50
research centers and Institute's he has
sustained and strengthened the
university's academic excellence and
expanded its interdisciplinary programs
and international partnerships while
making great strides in enhancing the
diversity of this core academic
community David's leadership and his
partnership with the school of general
studies led directly to the creation of
our newest international program the
dual be a program with Trinity College
Dublin the inaugural class of students
will arrive on campus in Dublin in
September on behalf of the faculty
administration students and alumni of
the school of general studies I want to
thank David for his service to the
University and for his friendship to GS
and to me personally as a small token of
our affection and gratitude we are
honored to present David with a signed
copy of our partnership agreement
between Columbia University and Trinity
College Dublin thank you David
okay thank you
each year the Alumni key is awarded to a
senior who has achieved distinction both
academically and through service to the
undergraduate community this year the
Alumni key award will be presented by
our distinguished alumna and co-chair of
the GS Alumni Association
Kirsty Jardine Kirstie is from
Johannesburg South Africa where she
worked as an emergency services
paramedic and market research project
administrator before moving to New York
City
she graduated from G s in May 2015 with
her BA in classical studies and very
close to my heart
cursey was the first student ever
accepted into G s is dual degree program
with Columbia's mailmen School of Public
Health completing her master's degree in
October 2016 she currently works at the
New York City Department of Health and
Mental Hygiene managing disaster
preparedness training for the Bureau of
emergency field operations the two
thousand alumni key award is awarded to
Kevin graves
originally from the Midwest
Kevin is a New Yorker for the last 20
years he is a successful DJ a music
producer with three top 20 billboard
dance remixes a transfer student from
LaGuardia Community College Kevin has
distinguished himself at Columbia as a
scholar and deeply engaged student
leader Kevin is a founding member and
leader of the Columbia recovery
coalition he has been a peer adviser a
volunteer peer advocate at the gay
health advocacy project where he
conducted HIV and STI counseling at
Columbia Health
he has been an active member of ivg a
conference for first-generation and
low-income students the LGBTQ leadership
retreat he is the Secretary of G s
Alliance and the Ivy Mental Health
Conference and my favorite of Kevin's
many contributions Kevin has been
participating on the JED substance use
working group which I am also a member
Kevin is an accomplished scholar he was
a finalist for both the Fulbright and
Truman scholarships this academic year
he received the Peter J on scholarship
after graduating
after graduation Kevin will pursue a PhD
in social welfare or clinical psychology
and this month Kevin will present
original research at the 30th
Association for psychological science
meeting Kevin Graves graduates with
honors in psychology magna laude and
as a member of the GS Honor Society
congratulations Kevin
[Applause]
I am particularly pleased this year to
present the third annual Campbell award
the Campbell award is given to a student
from each school at Columbia who shows
exceptional leadership and Columbia's
spirit as exemplified by the late Bill
Campbell Columbia College class of 1962
Teachers College class of 1964 share
emeritus of the board of trustees and
co-founder of the Columbia Alumni
Association the Campbell Award will
again be presented by co-chair of the GS
Alumni Association Christy Jardine the
winner of this year's Campbell award is
Powell masked leg
Paulo is the first in his family to
graduate college during his time in G s
Powell served as orientation leader in
junior marshal and he has served two
consecutive terms as the community
service representative on the general
study student council he was also the
undergraduate representative to the
presidential Advisory Committee on
sexual assault before becoming a student
to GS Powell served in America as a City
Year Corpse member and was a public ally
fellow at the u.s. fund for UNICEF
he had also worked for Habitat for
Humanity as a volunteer leader and
helped create an education based
nonprofit the great youth movement
Powell also served as the general body
chair of he freshy at Columbia the GS
policy representative to the Ivy Council
a sexual violence response peer educator
and a peer health exchange educator
after graduation Powell will be cycling
from San Francisco to Los Angeles Wow
for the San Francisco AIDS Foundation
and the Los Angeles LGBT Center and then
will be running from San Francisco to
Boston for the omen cancer funds he also
plans to join the Peace Corps to work on
HIV prevention in sub-saharan Africa
please join me in congratulating our
Campbell Award winner Powell Master
the remaining academic prizes and awards
for leadership were presented at the
student leadership and academic prizes
dinner on May 1st
please refer to your program for the
names of these extraordinary graduates
who represent in a compelling way the
Columbia tradition of academic
excellence and commitment to community
services now the part that we've all
been waiting for I'm going to ask Dean
Harford our Dean of Students to come up
good morning my name is Tom Harford on
the dean of students of the school of
general studies president Bollinger
executive vice president Madigan
president my own Dean Rosen met Jean
Valentini dean Schwartz vice president
Chang MS Cowan miss Jardine
distinguished faculty dedicated alumni
assembled guests it is my pleasure to
present to you our candidates for The
Bachelor of Arts in the school of
general studies class of 2018 each
degree candidate will receive a
certificate of achievement from
president Bollinger and will pause very
briefly to be photographed with Dean
Rosen mesh Kirstie Jardine GS class of
2015 will present each graduate with a G
s alumni pin wear this prin with pin
with pride and let it serve as a
reminder of your academic achievements
and your time spent Egeus now to the
wonderful supportive and vocal family
and friends that have gathered here
today I humbly ask that you please hold
your applause until the graduates have
been presented on stage we would not
want to have one family's excitement
drown out the presentation of another
proud families graduate I promise you
there will be plenty of opportunity for
applause and celebration when the
presentation of the class of 2018 is
concluded thank you so much for your
understanding and your restraint
with a few exceptions here and there
this year's class will be presented in
alphabetical order
approximately will the candidates for
the degree of Bachelor of Arts please
step forward
Calvin Christopher West men Middle
Eastern South Asian and African Studies
magna laude Aegeus Honor Society
powell Maslak Bachelor of Arts sociology
Campbell Award winner Kevin Edward
graves alumni key winner Bachelor of
Arts psychology magna laude Seiji
roseola Shu ding Bachelor of Arts
political science GS Honor Society magna
laude Augustine see you shower
Bachelor of Arts Classical Studies summa
laude Aegeus Honor Society Phi Beta
Kappa Roya dawn hag dull Bachelor of
Arts political science with a
concentration in Hispanic studies says
our a is araga Bachelor of Arts
mathematics
shuanzhu Bachelor of Arts art history
magna laude Gao Zhan Jiang Bachelor
of Arts mathematics statistics Jingzhou
Bachelor of Arts computer science say
Yasuda Bachelor of Arts data science
G Wilson Velasco Bachelor of Arts
political science Mary soul you Bachelor
of Arts psychology summa laude
Aegeus Honor Society Phi Beta Kappa
Justice Betty Bachelor of Arts political
science summa laude Aegeus Honor
Society Phi Beta Kappa Paulina Yamcha
cough Bachelor of Arts American Studies
with a concentration in Human Rights
summa laude Aegeus Honor Society
departmental honors American Studies Phi
Beta Kappa Alex woo Bachelor of Arts
history laude Shing ha woo Bachelor
of Arts mathematics statistics summa
laude Aegeus Honor Society departmental
honors Phi Beta Kappa
John Stanley woody Bachelor of Arts
Financial Economics Reuben Alan Young
Bachelor of Arts Urban Studies young Ben
you Bachelor of Arts computer science
and mathematics summa laude Aegeus
Honor Society Phi Beta Kappa gift Aki
Amir Bachelor of Arts economics and
sociology laude departmental honors
giochi young Bachelor of Arts sociology
concentration and statistics GS Honor
Society Constantina Costantino Villanova
Bachelor of Arts human rights with a
concentration in political science
Tenzin Sheng Wang Bachelor of Arts
economics laude Geoffrey Simon
Wolfson Bachelor of Arts English with a
concentration in mathematics Charles
Anthony Wujek Bachelor of Arts creative
writing
William Jewell Wong Bachelor of Arts
financial economics magna laude
Brendan Ryan Walsh Bachelor of Arts
Theater Arts laude departmental
honors Jordan David Whitlow Bachelor of
Arts mathematics statistics Michael
George weds Bachelor of Arts
anthropology summa laude Aegeus
Honor Society departmental honors Phi
Beta Kappa Thomas Brendan waters
Bachelor of Arts political science jacob
lewis wasserman bachelor of arts
psychology margarita busines rova
Bachelor of Arts of Visual Arts
Kimberly Carolyn vidur's Bachelor of
Arts creative writing summa laude
Aegeus Honor Society Phi Beta Kappa
Alexander Vera special of arts creative
writing double major in Hispanic studies
magna laude
Lara Sophie Tong Bachelor of Arts
biological sciences magna laude GS
Honor Society to jung-hwan Bachelor of
Arts mathematics statistics magna
laude GS Honor Society Marie Snodgrass
trams Bachelor of Arts psychology Pamela
Vande ended in arriba Bachelor of Arts
philosophy and psychology double major
magna laude Aegeus honors
xiety Julie Avril you Guerette special
of arts English laude Jeffrey C
you'd say Bachelor of Arts data science
Justin David Truglio Bachelor of Arts
neuroscience and behavior Anna Vladimir
suka Bachelor of Arts economics summa
laude Gia's Honor Society Phi Beta
Kappa Holly Ellen tosco Bachelor of Arts
economics philosophy
Melvin hi young jaha Bachelor of Arts
financial economics with a concentration
in business management Jake Brandon
Tischler Bachelor of Arts political
science laude kevin Ruhi - hey B
Bachelor of Arts psychology China tip
Tata yak Arun Wang Bachelor of Arts
anthropology summa laude GS Honor
Society departmental honors Phi Beta
Kappa Hannah Adrian sweet special of
Arts Earth Sciences GS Honor Society
healing son Bachelor of Arts mathematics
statistics magna laude GS Honor
Society
Meredith Densmore Sullivan Bachelor of
Arts political science magna laude H
es Honor Society
Lipton George Thompson Bachelor of Arts
visual arts
Ronald telemark Bachelor of Arts
mathematics Adam retailer Bachelor of
Arts biochemistry magna laude Gia's
Honor Society departmental honors
sureness and vern Bachelor of Arts
biophysics meteo Todd Contreras Bachelor
of Arts English laude departmental
honors Julius a laser tan Bachelor of
Arts political science magna laude
Aegeus Honor Society
Laila de holland esta Dan ger Bachelor
of Arts psychology laude
Kevin Sparrow Bachelor of Arts political
science magna laude Leon when young
song Bachelor of Arts computer science
magna laude
Yan song Bachelor of Arts physics summa
laude GS Honor Society departmental
honors Phi Beta Kappa Chantel Natalie
Ruben Bachelor of Arts Urban Studies
cheesy song Bachelor of Arts political
science Andru Edwards Solomon Bachelor
of Arts comparative literature and
society laude Ali Mabel Sinclair
Bachelor of Arts psychology laude
joseph Hani Talbot Bachelor of Arts
psychology laude daniel Heim towel
Bachelor of Arts computer science
laude
Ian Matthew Simonson Bachelor of Arts
neuroscience and behavior laude
Bremen some Bachelor of Arts computer
science David Eric Silverberg Bachelor
of Arts Middle Eastern South Asian and
African Studies magna laude
departmental honors Elizabeth rose
Siegel Bachelor of Arts Theater Arts
magna laude departmental honors
Anastacio Sidorenko v''e Bachelor of
Arts comparative literature and Society
magna laude Gia's Honor Society
Sofia
Roxana Setrakian Bachelor of Arts
ethnicity and race studies Henri Sosa
Bachelor of Arts information sciences
Samuel Evans Schechter Bachelor of Arts
neuroscience and behavior John Edward
Scannell Bachelor of Arts political
science jacob Mikhail's Schiffman
Bachelor of Arts English Jonah Shane
Scharf Bachelor of Arts history
yung-chun Bachelor of Arts East Asian
Studies magna laude Roy Siegel
Bachelor of Arts East Asian Studies with
a double major in economics Gia's Honor
Society Phi Beta Kappa summa laude
Mac ASEC Bachelor of Arts financial
economics Shane Sheldon Scott Bachelor
of Arts music laude
Raymond JWT Sante Magruder Bachelor of
Arts at katha architecture Jonathan
Joseph Segal Bachelor of Arts psychology
theatre Joseph Scopus Bachelor of Arts
political science
Nicholas Gerard Rowe Bachelor of Arts
anthropology Rena Susannah Schulberg
Bachelor of Arts psychology James Cole
Schofield Bachelor of Arts philosophy
with a concentration in computer science
laude Lazar Lipa Smeltzer Bachelor
of Arts double major in creative writing
and visual arts magna laude GS Honor
Society Farhan Sahil Bachelor of Arts
computer science magna laude matthew
john ryan Bachelor of Arts political
science Michael effin Rovin Rovner
Bachelor of Arts economics Mario Romero
Bachelor of Arts mathematics Andy
Alberto Rodriguez Bachelor of Arts
Hispanic studies laude card Carley
Rodriguez spatula arts film and Media
Studies
Daniel Philip red house Bachelor of Arts
with a double major in philosophy and
religion Rudy Rahman Bachelor of Arts
political science
William Rios Bachelor of Arts
mathematics statistics magna laude
GS Honor Society
Edward basil rust and Bachelor of Arts
creative writing
Jacqueline Shire rudik Bachelor of Arts
comparative literature in society summa
laude Aegeus Honor Society Phi Beta
Kappa andrei rublyov Bachelor of Arts
economics picture Alfonzo Ria's Bachelor
of Arts Financial Economics Erik Steven
Reinhart Bachelor of Arts Financial
Economics Zachary Taylor Richards
Bachelor of Arts East Asian Studies
Israel Reyes Bachelor of Arts history
with a concentration in business
management
gusta Ramaswamy Bachelor of Arts urban
studies Donnie Keith Rada Bachelor of
Arts sociology summa laude GS Honor
Society Phi Beta Kappa Roy pre got
Bachelor of Arts computer science magna
laude GS Honor Society
Thomas Morgan prendre Ville Bachelor of
Arts computer science
Gregory Keith pred more a Bachelor of
Arts political science college Oliva
nave Revo a Bachelor of Arts Middle
Eastern South Asian and African Studies
with a double major in political science
summa laude GS Honor Society Phi
Beta Kappa
Ryan render bachelor of arts philosophy
laude Tseng boom Rob Bachelor of
Arts political science sana Armony
Quigley Bachelor of Arts Women's and
Gender Studies summa laude AJ's
Honor Society Phi Beta Kappa
departmental honors Matthew Fang chunk
wek Bachelor of Arts political science
concentration in computer science
Jane Hunter Pope Bachelor of Arts
English summa laude Aegeus Honor
Society Phi Beta Kappa Christopher Craig
Patterson Bachelor of Arts film and
Media Studies magna laude Aegeus
Honor Society film studies departmental
honors Shanna ray Polly Bachelor of Arts
music pyrrole Ogden Bachelor of Arts
economics and political science
Eric o your bid Bachelor of Arts
mathematics statistics gilead Norman
Penn Bachelor of Arts computer science
purnima Chadha reap and earthy Bachelor
of Arts psychology Corey
Alexander puller Bowers Bachelor of Arts
English magna laude
Maurice is on floor pruney a Bachelor of
Arts political science magna laude
AG s Honor Society Kimberly Ann Pizzuti
Bachelor of Arts English magna laude
Aegeus Honor Society Phi Beta Kappa ena
pilipenko bachelor of arts philosophy
min time on palm Bachelor of Arts data
science magna laude GS Honor Society
departmental honors Gabriella Moreira
Palmer Bachelor of Arts sociology magna
laude
Adam Johnathan Pawlowski Bachelor of
Arts
science Rachael grace patent Petrov arts
political science magna laude Casey
James O'Brien Bachelor of Arts
anthropology yuck Daniel Novak Bachelor
of Arts religion Julianne Nietzsche
special of arts neuroscience in behavior
summa laude GS Honor Society Phi
Beta Kappa Kezia houin Park Bachelor of
Arts economics Mert Kovac Baker Bachelor
of Arts political science magna
laude
Michelle s pack Bachelor of Arts
Financial Economics Erin leap at Tech
Bachelor of Arts Financial Economics
Honor Society summa laude Miami
Otsuki Bachelor of Arts financial
economics magna laude GS Honor
Society
Jennifer Maia usher Bachelor of Arts
French and francophone studies patchak
on giveth Bachelor of Arts economics
Enric Allen olavo Bachelor of Arts
political science statistics
Samantha Pascoe Bachelor of Arts human
rights Aneesa Julianna Peterson Bachelor
of Arts human rights
Eldad Niemeyer Bachelor of Arts Middle
Eastern South Asian and African Studies
mehran reza mohan Najafi Bachelor of
Arts economics Brittany Nagi Bachelor of
Arts political science summa laude
GS Honor Society Phi Beta Kappa orally
Michelle Morgan Bachelor of Arts
evolutionary biology of the human
species magna laude Cornelia Maria
Ogando Bachelor of Arts sustainable
development
Kimmie Lynn Nakota Bachelor of Arts
neuroscience and behavior summa
laude Aegeus Honor Society
Ashley can nunu ghen Bachelor of Arts
computer science
phung chang now Bachelor of Arts
financial economics magna laude he
dodged our Myeong Bachelor of Arts
Information Sciences summa laude
Aegeus Honor Society
Emma Clara Murphy Bachelor of Arts
political science Juan Mata Cabo
ammonia's Bachelor of Arts history
Daniel Steven MacFarlane Bachelor of
Arts political science magna laude
Aegeus Honor Society
shaf is open Mazar
Bachelor of Arts physics jung-wook moon
Bachelor of Arts political science
laude Wilmer Angel montedio Seska
bachelor of arts history Summa
commodious Honor Society a beam of
mahabharath Bachelor of Arts financial
economics laude shinja men Bachelor
of Arts psychology Maximilian Musburger
Bachelor of Arts financial economics
magna laude elizabeth and Miller
Bachelor of Arts English magna laude
Gia's Honor Society Thomas Robert Miller
Bachelor of Arts astrophysics Daniel
McKinley and Bachelor of Arts economics
laude Walter gave her Mayer Bachelor
of Arts computer science
Queenie Lowell Bachelor of Arts religion
with a concentration in physics summa
laude Gia's Honor Society
departmental honors Phi Beta Kappa guild
that hold Bachelor of Arts Financial
Economics Erin Kathy Lowry Bachelor of
Arts English a Neath command Dava
Bachelor of Arts economics philosophy
Elizabeth and Manchester Bachelor of
Arts creative writing
Sarah Nicole McMaster Bachelor of Arts
biological sciences Cameron Lee McMahon
Bachelor of Arts sustainable development
laude see who a mang Bachelor of
Arts mathematics statistics laude
daniel mira vish special heart
sustainable development nicholas
alexander Mattos Bachelor of Arts
psychology Claudia Matson a Bachelor of
Arts biological sciences Evan Martinez
Bachelor of Arts physics Laila Martinez
Bachelor of Arts human rights
concentration in sociology
Tamila pasha a al Damari Bachelor of
Arts economics magna laude GS Honor
Society
Yao Chen Lin Bachelor of Arts biological
sciences summa laude GS Honor
Society Phi Beta Kappa Mark Glenn
Bachelor of Arts economics with a double
major in political science magna
laude sarah elizabeth Lytle Bachelor of
Arts sustainable development laude
jennifer elizabeth lutz Bachelor of Arts
creative writing
Matthew Leo let's special of arts
political science
Madison Siri Marlowe Bachelor of Arts
political science magna laude Bowen
Mao Bachelor of Arts computer science
magna laude Aegeus Honor Society
Laurence whether Hill Madsen bachelor of
arts history laude
Mona Marti c'mon bachelor of arts media
and film studies why Sean MA Bachelor of
Arts psychology summa laude GS Honor
Society departmental honors Phi Beta
Kappa and Lydia Hyman Bachelor of Arts
psychology laude
hi Jin Lee Bachelor of Arts economics
political science magna laude G us
Honor Society daniel south leap our
Bachelor of Arts sustainable development
magna laude Immanuel M lemon F
Bachelor of Arts computer science
Daniel Aman Bachelor of Arts Financial
Economics summa laude GS Honor
Society
Lawrence George lens and Bachelor of
Arts mathematics Xiao Tong Lin Bachelor
of Arts mathematics statistics magna
laude GS Honor Society Kathryn new
Bachelor of Arts political science
laude
Irina Luo Bachelor of Arts economic
environmental science magna laude GS
Honor Society departmental honors Phi
Beta Kappa
Emily Ruth Lippmann Bachelor of Arts
film and Media Studies LaRon Lippman
Bachelor of Arts economics Matthew
LaMacchia Bachelor of Arts political
science laude Natasha
hiya hi Dean erendor Bachelor of Arts
Theater Arts with a concentration in
mathematics summa laude Gia's Honor
Society Phi Beta Kappa departmental
honors Amir La Vie Bachelor of Arts
computer science Matthew Theory Bernard
LaRoque Bachelor of Arts economics
political science
Julian Anthony larosa Bachelor of Arts
creative writing with a double major in
political science
ung Qwark Bachelor of Arts economics
jong-hyun Kwok Bachelor of Arts
economics Jacob Lozano Bachelor of Arts
financial economics jacob max Lewis
Bachelor of Arts data science laude
Celine Lazard Brant Bachelor of Arts
Urban Studies summa laude GS Honor
Society departmental honors
Madeline Isabelle Letty Bachelor of Arts
comparative literature in society summa
laude Aegeus Honor Society Phi Beta
Kappa departmental honors ecology of
Bachelor of Arts computer science
Olivier Jean Kim Bachelor of Arts music
concentration of Biological Sciences
departmental honors Julian hands your
Koecher Bachelor of Arts computer
science Michael Allen Kling Bachelor of
Arts biochemistry Sarah Aikido Clini
Bachelor of Arts creative writing summa
laude Gia's Honor Society Wang Yong
Kim Bachelor of Arts computer science
magna laude Gia's Honor Society
Michael William Law Bachelor of Arts
physics concentration in mathematics
Alisa Ruth Crew denier Bachelor of Arts
Middle Eastern South Asian and African
Studies magna laude
Gabriela Elizabeth Kovacs spectral of
arts psychology Nikolai he wrote
Kentucky Bachelor of Arts history
concentration business management gia
Saunders society Phi Beta Kappa Albert
Evan Kohn Bachelor of Arts religion
summa laude Gia's Honor Society
Tracey and Jimena Bachelor of Arts
biological sciences laude michael
anthony price Bachelor of Arts ethnicity
and race studies magna laude Aegeus
Honor Society dowdy Justin Bachelor of
Arts political science Michael Anthony
cuvee Bachelor of Arts economic nakooma
laude kiri Yong Kim Bachelor of Arts
biological sciences summa laude
Aegeus Honor Society departmental honors
Phi Beta Kappa June yell Kim Bachelor of
Arts financial economics with a
concentration in political science magna
laude GS Honor Society me Yong Kim
Bachelor of Arts political science
concentration East Asian Studies summa
laude GS Honor Society Phi Beta
Kappa young hoon Kim Bachelor of Arts
mathematics statistics Daniel Kim
Bachelor of Arts political science Ji
Young Kim Bachelor of Arts mathematics
magna laude Judah kill sir Bachelor
of Arts major in English concentration
psychology summa laude GS Honor
Society Phi Beta Kappa Noah make a
hottie Bachelor of Arts Middle Eastern
South Asian and African Studies
laude
Erica Brianna Kawaguchi Bachelor of Arts
human rights with psychology
concentration summa
cloudy GS honor society Phi Beta Kappa
Alice Jiang Bachelor of Arts Financial
Economics Courtney Elizabeth Jewett
Bachelor of Arts English and comparative
literature magna laude david ellis
Jeter Bachelor of Arts Italian later
shoe summa laude Phi Beta Kappa GS
Honor Society
min ji Kang Bachelor of Arts mathematics
statistics magna laude
Jonathan Arjun Khanna cassabi Bachelor
of Arts economics mathematics tina
Jitendra khanna Bachelor of Arts
biological sciences laude
Cody ray Katz bachelor of arts
philosophy magna laude departmental
honors GS Honor Society Christopher
Reeve Jones Bachelor of Arts creative
writing
George Kyle Johnson Bachelor of Arts
data science laude
Desmond Richard Johnson Bachelor of Arts
economics Adam Lee John Bachelor of Arts
comparative literature and society Sean
Michael Jarvis Bachelor of Arts
political science concentration in
business management summa laude gia
Saunders society Phi Beta Kappa Thomas
Jane hat James Hansen Hannon Bachelor of
Arts evolutionary biology of the human
species concentration of visual arts
James Hahn Bachelor of Arts political
science David J Haynes Bachelor of Arts
philosophy
double major in psychology Arielle
Hillman Bachelor of Arts economics
statistics summa laude GS Honor
Society Phi Beta Kappa Elizabeth Harris
Bachelor of Arts environmental biology
Ezra Hurwitz bachelor of arts film and
media studies laude Tennyson
Jeffords E Bachelor of Arts Slovak
studies with a concentration in
psychology summa laude Phi Beta
Kappa GS Honor Society Matthew Ryan
Hatari Bachelor of Arts political
science Ronald Andrew Hewitt Bachelor of
Arts creative writing
yee-haw hong Bachelor of Arts
mathematics statistics summa laude
GS Honor Society
Chao Hong Bachelor of Arts economics
Suzanne lui no loo room Bachelor of Arts
economics yawn easy Gordon Bachelor of
Arts Financial Economics Jacob Samuel
good when Bachelor of Arts Middle
Eastern South Asian and African Studies
Vanessa Wolfe Bachelor of Arts
sustainable development Jonathan Michael
Harper Bachelor of Arts evolutionary
biology of the human species
magna laude departmental honors
Miklos her and a Bachelor of Arts
economics Minji Hong Bachelor of Arts
Human Rights mark Nathan her special of
arts history laude daniel a
Hernandez special of arts financial
economics Lucas Didrik how de Burgh
Bachelor of Arts political science summa
laude GS Honor Society departmental
honors Phi Beta Kappa Jane Ellen Haseman
Bachelor of Arts political science
sociology laude Amy Lee fuzz kiss
Bachelor of Arts Theater Arts
Jeremy Andrey calvess Bachelor of Arts
economics Gabriella Da Vida Ginsberg
Fletcher Bachelor of Arts sustainable
development laude iman lee gilles
petrov arts political science with a
concentration Middle Eastern South Asian
and African Studies magna laude gia
society Benjamin Kyle Gersten Bachelor
of Arts neuroscience and behavior with a
concentration in Wis --tx laude
andrew Pierre Gerson Bachelor of Arts
political science laude
Sebastian Thomas Gershman Bachelor of
Arts political science alex Guarino
Bachelor of Arts economics ping Chang
Gwon bachelor of arts history laude
Xiang ji Xue bachelor of arts
architecture miles Jacob Grinspoon
Bachelor of Arts American Studies Joe
Nagy and hayah Goldman K Bachelor of
Arts art history magna laude C Pingo
matter of arts astrophysics magna
laude
Estelle ow d Danny Oh Bachelor of Arts
sociology with a concentration in
statistics samantha Gabriel Frewer
bachelor of arts architecture magna
laude departmental honors GS Honor
Society
Shannon Bo RAM freed Bachelor of Arts
anthropology laude
Jo Deline Christina France Bachelor of
Arts political science double major in
psychology
Steven Michael Francis special of arts
statistics ephone Gow a Bachelor of Arts
computer science magna laude GS
Honor Society
Thomas Germain Bachelor of Arts American
Studies summa laude gia Saunders
society Phi Beta Kappa
Jacqueline Diana George Bachelor of Arts
history Chabot Jenna View Bachelor of
Arts economics GS
Society Isabel Murray Galentine Oh
Bachelor of Arts sociology Brenda and
Wesley Gaines Bachelor of Arts English
concentration in Hispanic studies
laude
Margaret Wiley foeman Bachelor of Arts
music magna laude Gia's Honor
Society Benjamin Harrison Fox's Bachelor
of Arts neuroscience and behavior
Edward Henning constant Erickson
Bachelor of Arts computer science
laude Aegeus Honor Society
Elena Rosa Eng comenzado Bachelor of
Arts ethnicity and race studies magna
laude departmental honors GS Honor
Society Elin and flax special of arts
sociology magna laude julia annette
Flass Fowler Bachelor of Arts English
magna laude
Trevor Gil Felix broad Bachelor of Arts
political science summa laude GS
Honor Society Phi Beta Kappa Denise
frutos Bachelor of Arts psychology Kevin
Preston Marcus Francis special of arts
creative writing with a concentration in
african-american studies come out a
departmental honors Brett Nero's fight
Bachelor of Arts creative writing GS
Honor Society magna laude
Josie's and a fuzzy no Bachelor of Arts
psychology marchin fogger whose special
of arts
computer science louise our Cruz
Bachelor of Arts political science
Karolina G hi Troy Bachelor of Arts
psychology Jacob Arne doll Bachelor of
Arts political science laude
christopher Hamilton Durham bachelor of
arts philosophy summa laude
departmental honors Gia's honor society
Phi Beta Kappa Jessica Doyle Bachelor of
Arts Latin American and Caribbean
studies magna laude summa laude
actually GS Honor Society
Sabrina Jimmy O Bachelor of Arts Human
Rights political science double major
summa laude Aegeus Honor Society
Ryan David fad and Bachelor of Arts
sociology michael amon Falkenstein
Bachelor of Arts computer science with a
concentration in mathematics
Jonathan Robert Ellsworth Bachelor of
Arts and computer science Lewis Louise
McGavin Eldridge Bachelor of Arts
creative writing laude
aya tara l kosugi Bachelor of Arts human
rights Marc Anthony Eden Bachelor of
Arts economics jennifer Madeleine fall
said a Bachelor of Arts physics
Joseph Abraham Cooper bachelor of arts
philosophy laude david avery Cohen
Bachelor of Arts neuroscience and
behavior laude
Charlotte sage koban Bachelor of Arts
creative writing laude
Veronica cibulkov Bachelor of Arts
sociology magna laude GS Honor
Society Silvia lead Eton bachelor of
arts art history summa laude AJ's
Honor Society Phi Beta Kappa Emile
Christian Devon Bachelor of Arts Theater
Arts
sweepy Bachelor of Arts canine studies
David Martin L man Bachelor of Arts
human rights magna laude GS Honor
Society
Nathan Andrew Ekman bachelor of arts
history magna laude Jesus Honor
Society departmental honors Alexis Marie
daz Bachelor of Arts anthropology Jenna
Doogie awara Bachelor of Arts chemistry
Pierre Timmins Denton Bachelor of Arts
political science
samantha de messier Bachelor of Arts
Middle Eastern South Asian and African
Studies
anter colada caldera Beals Bachelor of
Arts human rights with a double major in
Middle Eastern South Asian and African
Studies magna laude departmental
honors Alexandria Andrew kanaeva CH
Sherman achieve Bachelor of Arts
Financial Economics Kwan Cal Chang
Bachelor of Arts physics magna laude
GS Honor Society
no Akasha cosmic McCoy Bachelor of Arts
sociology with a concentration in
statistics christina D Charles Bachelor
of Arts computer science ronald soon
Chang Bachelor of Arts political science
Ryan does Cosmo Bachelor of Arts
computer science
Raymond Hill record a special of arts
political science Polly Marguerite
Curran Bachelor of Arts history
Ferran and Crumpton Bachelor of Arts
sociology Sol Weatherford Courtney
Bachelor of Arts astrophysics Jose
Rudolph Caballero Bachelor of Arts
political science Paris Gachet Vic
Bachelor of Arts political science
Marvin Aikens blue Bachelor of Arts film
and Media Studies
Milot Delaney Burke Bachelor of Arts
economics
Ellen Carbajal Bachelor of Arts
psychology
Maxine Theo Jacques Capone Bachelor of
Arts mathematics summa laude GS
Honor Society Phi Beta Kappa
Isabella Canal Bachelor of Arts
biochemistry
Donald Michael Castle a Bachelor of Arts
psychology florian supo Bachelor of Arts
Urban Studies ablative cherry B Hasani
Bachelor of Arts economics mathematics
laude christina Cho Bachelor of Arts
politicals biological sciences Jessie
Benton cherry Bachelor of Arts human
rights anthony james chan Bachelor of
Arts computer science magna laude
and cloudy GS Honor Society
Andrew David Bates Bachelor of Arts
visual arts magna laude departmental
honors Colin James Barrett Bachelor of
Arts American Studies Stephen Wesley
Barker Bachelor of Arts economics
mathematics summa laude geus Honor
Society Phi Beta Kappa nationally Boras
Bachelor of Arts computer science a soft
Bonnie Bachelor of Arts economics
laude louise boguslav Bachelor of Arts
computer science Ln C Kate's Eileen CKC
Bachelor of Arts history Corinna and
case Bachelor of Arts psychology magna
laude christina marie carter a
Bachelor of Arts creative writing
concentration in jazz study magna
laude Kaylee and boots boots Bachelor of
Arts political science Daniel our
burkhart Bachelor of Arts information
sciences Nathan Andrew Burgess Bachelor
of Arts computer science Stacey Rosanna
Burt Bachelor of Arts sociology summa
laude Jesus Honor Society Phi Beta
Kappa Stefan been conceived Bachelor of
Arts political science summa laude
GS Honor Society departmental honors
Joseph Dilip Akane Bachelor of Arts
psychology with a concentration in East
Asian Studies
Saba Rachel Ascari Bachelor of Arts
visual arts Julie Lee Bachelor of Arts
psychology with a concentration in
business management
Katherine by Bachelor of Arts statistics
Andrew Belmar Brooks Bachelor of Arts
Middle Eastern South Asian African
Studies magna laude AGS Honor
Society
Derek Jason Berg Bachelor of Arts
psychology Jessica Bennett Bachelor of
Arts ethnicity race studies summa
laude GS Honor Society
Nathan Shinji Ben Jack Bachelor of Arts
computer science Sara Lee Belle's
Bachelor of Arts sociology
Chenoa van rider dov' Bachelor of Arts
political science
Baudelaire Jean Charles Bachelor of Arts
applied mathematics Christopher Michael
Garrity Bachelor of Arts political
science Christopher Michael a jello
Bachelor of Arts political science lel
odd as acquits Bachelor of Arts classics
summa laude G astonish society
departmental honors Phi Beta Kappa
Nicole Marie baya Bachelor of Arts Human
Rights Supriya
Loni Bachelor of Arts Urban Studies
laude Marc tongue Chabot Bachelor of
Arts computer science with a
concentration in psychology summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa
Emily Holland below Xion Bachelor of
Arts sustainable development magna
laude GS Honor Society
Andrew Wyatt Baker Bachelor of Arts East
Asian Studies
Jeffrey Scott Bailey Bachelor of Arts
evolutionary biology of the human
species magna laude
Jane's sunflower beer Bachelor of Arts
financial economics laude
Michael Michal aundrea Marko Ashkenazi
Bachelor of Arts Urban Studies magna
laude
Manpreet Singh Bachelor of Arts
economics mathematics Johanna Emily
rinds Bachelor of Arts anthropology
magna laude matthew Maddock Arnold
Bachelor of Arts political science
laude
Roberto Antonio are availble of Arts
film and Media Studies with a business
concentration Benjamin Benjamin Samuel
Aaron Steen bachelor of arts history
magna laude departmental honors
Soledad Alena Anderson Bachelor of Arts
human rights
Rebecca and Anderson Bachelor of Arts
applied mathematics
Alexis Martha Allen Bachelor of Arts
economics math out Christoph is our
Bachelor of Arts political science lule
Abramowitz Bachelor of Arts political
science summa laude Honor Society
Ian Richard Alderman Bachelor of Arts
eken
comics next Imola Bachelor of Arts
anthropology William Alejandro Falcone
Bachelor of Arts data science with a
concentration in mathematics comedy
jung-hyun Bachelor of Arts history Wow
all right
okay
well the class of 2018 please rise
ladies and gentlemen I am proud to
present to you the unique gifted scrappy
savvy and always inspiring General
Studies class of 2018 thank you please
be seated
[Applause]
congratulations again our valedictorian
this year is justice Betty
born and raised in Toronto Canada
justice knew from the age of four that
she wanted to run for political office
in her home country and in the ensuing
years pursued volunteer positions in
government and on more than a dozen
political campaigns she represented
Canada in the world
individually individual debating and
public speaking championships in 2012 in
2014 when she was named one of the top
20 best high school public speakers in
the world her interest in politics is
driven by a fundamental commitment to
improving the daily lives of individuals
in the areas that affect them most
access to education healthcare and
employment at age 17 justice was
admitted to the dual BA program between
Columbia University and Seon suppo she
served as vice president of the Columbia
organization of rising entrepreneurs a
Columbia Representative to the United
Nations Youth Forum and an organizer for
Columbia's first Women's Conference she
opened the door
all throughout justice has remained
active in Canadian politics frequently
traveling between New York Toronto and
Ottawa to speak about youth engagement
and female representation in
government's a member of the GS Honor
Society justice has been named to the
Dean's List every semester is a member
of Pi Sigma Alpha the national political
science Honor Society and is a recipient
of the deans scholarship she graduates
with far better than an A average with
two bachelor's degrees one in social
sciences from science Po and one in
political science from Columbia summa
laude and is a member of the Phi
Beta Kappa after graduating justice will
return to Toronto to join McKinsey &
Company
I suspect however that it will not be
long before justice hears her four year
old self compelling her to even greater
heights all we can say is watch out
Justin Tora Trudeau please join me in
welcoming the valedictorian of the class
of 2018 Justice Betty
Wow
thank you for that introduction deed
match good morning esteemed Columbia
University administrators faculty alumni
family friends and most importantly
congratulations to the GS class of 2018
my preschool teachers were the first to
ask me what my dream job was in a circle
surrounded by my friends I shared my
dream I continued to catch up with the
same teachers and every time we see each
had there they asked me if I still want
to be the Prime Minister of Canada 17
years later I still reply yes childhood
is sacred for many reasons we can sleep
as much as we want plays encouraged and
our minds are subject to infinite wonder
unhindered by the so called realities of
life we are encouraged to dream big and
the notion of impossible is practically
invisible my own testimony as a
four-year-old is an important reminder
of the purest hopes and biggest dreams I
had for myself here on our graduation
day we have more in common with our four
year old selves though we may wish to
admit in addition to still finding it
difficult to sit through a series of
long speeches we will never be as free
as we are in this moment and the freedom
to innovate hope and dream will one day
be taken away from us if we let it as we
get older the question what is your
dream job is replaced with so what's
next and our childhood answers are
becoming a zoo keeper an astronaut or an
NBA player seem distant as we linkedin
DM a distressed debt investment analyst
whether it is a move across the ocean a
change in our personal lives or a career
pivot we are asked what's next at every
monumental moment in our lives
this question has dominated our
conversations with our peers colleagues
teachers and just about every single
member of our extended family at every
holiday gathering not to mention the
dreaded what are you even going to do
with that political science
are you sure didn't want to study a real
science but most importantly what's next
is a question that has kept many of us
up at night unable to dream because
reality is a loud wake-up call but after
a string of what's next let us use this
occasion this occasion of our graduation
to glance back to the question what is
your dream notwithstanding this incoming
tide of pressures and expectations as
new graduates we can still preserve our
propensity as four-year-olds to dream
without limits as we walk across the
stage we walk through a confluence of
dreams
abilities and opportunities we can
design and craft our future and use the
tools of this education and experience
to execute practically we can glance
back to moments when our hopes seemed
infinite moments like this on our
graduation day or some of our earliest
articulations of our dreams to our
elementary school teachers this week we
will officially become graduates
graduates of Columbia University and
recipients of one of the best education
in the world
and what are we supposed to do with that
our dreams will be put to the test as we
enter the real world and are confronted
with this seemingly irresolvable
struggle between our dreams and reality
crossing the stage in our pale blue caps
and gowns marks the end of a time that
began in a tent quite similar to this
one many of us will remember a
convocation when Dean Harford asked the
crowd of incoming students to stand if
they're the first in their families to
attend University if it transferred from
a Community College if they're an
international dual be a student
working full-time to support their
education a parent of veteran new to New
York or a native New Yorker after a few
moments we were all proudly standing
looking around at our new classmates and
future best friends
simultaneously inspired and intimidated
since first stepping foot on this campus
some of us have produced Broadway shows
cycled across America for cancer and
volunteered in refugee camps today we
took several steps to get that paper and
that paper as a reminder of how far we
have come all that we have accomplished
and above all our diploma is symbolic of
just how much more we have left to do we
the class of 2018 stand at history's
door for history is behind us and it is
also in front of us for the history that
has been made has brought us here and
the history that we now have the
opportunity to make she'll be what
inspires us as we go forward and our
dreams have the power to illuminate our
paths as we take our next steps this
year marks 55 years since dr. dr. Martin
Luther King Junior's I have a dream
speech if anything history has taught us
about the power of dreams for his dreams
that fuel revolutions and humankind has
never conquered any new frontier without
finding inspiration and something that
was first planted as a black graduate at
both Columbia University and science Po
and valedictorian of the GS class of
2018 I am my ancestors wildest dreams I
graduate alongside undocumented students
who are their ancestors wildest dreams
and it is the dreams of all of our
parents teachers communities and
ourselves that have brought us to this
exact moment and it is our dreams that
will sustain us and in doris if we let
them
what is your dream for yourself at this
moment and who do you dream of becoming
as you reflect take a moment to listen
to the four year old dreamer that
quietly resonates inside of you as a
fresh graduate your answer today is
particularly valuable it retains that
preschool optimism and infuses a set of
skills and practicality that can make
that dream a reality
take for example the young girl that
once dreamt of being an astronaut who
has since realized that she is happier
on earth working at an aerospace startup
to bring herself and thousands like her
to space one day what's even more
special @gs is that through embracing
the non-traditional some of you did live
your dream job and now the question
becomes what will the ballerina or
published author dream of next what is
going to tie you to these raw hopes for
yourself how will you preserve the
spirit of dreams when reality seems to
hit so hard and the camps can quickly
outnumber the cans I'm not naive to the
fact that dreams can change or evolve or
that dreams are sometimes more material
than noble noble but how do we preserve
the desire to dream or will to wonder
especially when life's interruptions and
distractions will readily sideline these
dreams how do we preserve the passion
hunger energy engagement and optimism we
have right now the answer is right in
front of us just like a convocation we
can take an opportunity to look around
at all of our peers I'm so inspired as I
reflect on the fact that as graduates of
GS we are proof that through hard work
and determination no dream is too big
many of us have done the impossible
having followed a non-traditional path
contending with college life struggles
alongside real-life struggles from
working full-time
to raising a family and our presence
today and our successes are proof of
what can happen when we take the
opportunity or take a moment in our busy
lives to dream yes we know full well
that we are venturing into societies and
communities where we see shifting
realities and were several stances of
bitterness and recriminations have been
planted and where the harvest for it is
fake is plenty but at the same moment in
history we are watching our peers both
on this campus and Beyond become more
aware embracing activism and fighting
for change be inspired by your peers and
yourself when you encounter a challenge
that provokes self-doubt or anxiety
again glance back to remind yourself of
all that you have accomplished all
they've overcome to bring you to this
very moment in time marshal your courage
and use these experiences to push
forward with this internalized strength
in yourself and belief in yourself and
what is possible class of 2018 this is
our moment this is our moment to fashion
history in our own image and likeness
and through the power of this education
and our community we can fiercely
challenge the status quo and create the
change that we seek together we can
bring our dreams of a better day to life
we graduate from University and this
Oasis of self-discovery but the learning
continues we may leave the libraries and
lounges behind but we graduate as
members of a community with a network of
peers and lifelong friends maybe learn
from our friends such as a psychology
major volunteering his time to support
transgender youth and their families or
the mother who is tirelessly advocating
for the dreams of formerly in cars
students to access an education may our
work and service give voice to the
dreams of our communities and our world
may we commit to helping each other
keep these dreams alive most importantly
our our graduation is an affirmation of
the power of dreams those gone by that
established belief and those we shall
use to inspire us going forward and set
the foundation for achievement and
change it is dreamers that change the
world and we are all dreamers and within
us lies the power of change as graduates
of the Columbia University school of
general studies we shall not fear the
future we shall embrace it
congratulations gs class of 2018 thank
you
Wow
thank you both to justice and Marisol
for your incredible talks and again to
sasha cohen as our class day speaker
congratulations to the graduates of the
class of 2018 and congratulations take a
moment and look out on both sides and
thank and congratulate your families and
those who are here to support you today
as the first class to graduate in my
first semester is dean you will always
hold a special place in my heart
i am honored to be your dean for now and
for years to come as together we build a
very strong alumni community it's a new
era of alumni leadership and we welcome
you to our alumni association you embody
in a spectacular way the mission and
vision of columbia school of general
studies and columbia university i hope
you will stay involved with your
columbia family for many years to come i
now invite you and your families and
friends and loved ones to continue the
celebration at the class day reception
to be held under the tents on Avery
Plaza as you exit there will be student
marshals ready to guide you to the
reception since we are all headed to the
same place I ask that our guests remain
seated and allow the party on on stage
here to exit first then our graduates
will exit followed by family and friends
thank you and congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]